10 Famous Superhero Movies That Got The COSTUMES
All Wrong
It's always exciting when a superhero movie
is released to see how the characters in them
are going to look in live action.
In a lot of cases, they look fantastic.
Ben Affleck's Batman, Ryan Reynolds' most
recent Deadpool, Robert Downey, Jr.'s Iron
Man and Tom Hiddleston's Loki all looked great,
for example - but that's not always the case.
Whether it's because they were vastly different
from the classic costumes seen in the comic
books, or because the actors hated wearing
them, or because the fans just didn't take
to them at all, costumes in superhero movies
have been the source of a lot of controversy
over the years.That applies to both heroes
and villains and this video will take a look
at some prime examples.
Here are ten famous superhero movies that
got the costumes all wrong.
Deadpool in X-Men Origins: Wolverine
Thankfully, we've now had a cinematic version
of Deadpool worthy of praise - he looked awesome
in 2016, even if his costume and makeup did
make it impossible for Ryan Reynolds to even
sit down - but, back in 2009, in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine, we were given a version of the
character that was all wrong - especially
with regards to the way he looked and the
way he was dressed.He looked more like Baraka
from the Mortal Kombat video game series than
he looked like Deadpool from the comic books
- and he was infamously nicknamed “Barakapool“
as a result.
In addition to having his mouth sewn shut,
he wore simple elastic top pants and no top,
instead of Deadpool's famous all over red
and black uniform.
It really was horrendous in every respect.
Daredevil in Daredevil
We may have a great live action version of
Daredevil on the small screen these days,
and Ben Affleck might have finally proven
his worth as a superhero in Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice, but nobody will forget how
bad 2003's Daredevil movie was in a hurry
- not least because of how silly the man without
fear looked in his costume in the movie.The
hero of Hell's Kitchen is blind, so you can
forgive him for his poor choice, but the fact
is that his red leather costume made him look
like a male dominatrix.
It genuinely looked as though it would make
a squeaking noise every time Daredevil moved
and the tiny protruding horns on the headpiece
made it look like something a child would
wear to dress up as the Devil on Halloween.
It's the type of thing you'd wear if you wanted
to whip people while they were suspended in
a sex swing but, for fighting crime on the
mean streets?
Absolutely not.
It also has a visible zip.
No superhero costume should ever have a visible
zip.
Hal Jordan in Green Lantern
CGI is a big part of Hollywood these days
- and even costumes that are mostly practical
can be augmented with some computer-generated
imagery - but 2011's Green Lantern movie went
a step further than any superhero movie before
it by making the lead character's costume
entirely CGI.The idea was that the suit was
created by Hal Jordan's Green Lantern Ring
and was made of pure energy, but the end result
wasn't great.
It just didn't look natural and didn't seem
to combine harmoniously with the live action
actor wearing it - and when that actor has
the superhero-esque body of Ryan Reynolds,
you'd expect better.
Reynolds himself also stressed that the bodysuit
that he had to wear in order for the costume
to be generated over it must have been made
of "actual woven misery", given how uncomfortable
it made him feel - and he even made reference
to how bad the costume itself was in his latest
superhero outing as Deadpool.
John Constantine in Constantine
If there's one thing that DC and Vertigo Comics'
John Constantine is known for, it's his iconic
beige trench coat.
And what one thing did 2005's Constantine
movie seemingly forget to give the character?
You got it - his iconic beige trench coat.Keanu
Reeves starred as the character in the somewhat
underrated movie, but the item of clothing
he is so notable for wearing in the comic
books was very conspicuous in its absence.
Instead, he wore a long black coat.
And while it wasn't terrible and didn't make
him look silly or anything, it just wasn't
Constantine.
Thankfully, we have since had a live action
Constantine television series, starring Matt
Ryan in the titular role, in which the character
did wear a beige trench coat - but that's
now been cancelled.
Scarlet Witch in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
When Elizabeth Olsen first appeared in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as Scarlet Witch
in the mid-credits scene of Captain America:
The Winter Soldier in 2014, it was very exciting
for fans.
Since then, she's appeared in 2015's Avengers:
Age of Ultron and 2016's Captain America:
Civil War as the character - and, to be fair
to the actress, she's been great - but her
costume is incredibly boring compared to the
comic book version of the character.Classically,
Scarlet Witch wears a very sexy red outfit
that shows a lot of flesh, and it comes complete
with a red cape and a headdress, but the MCU
version wears what are essentially everyday
clothes.
There's some red in the costume, but that's
as far as the similarities with the comic
version go.
It might be unrealistic to hope for a costume
identical to the one in the comics to appear
on screen - Olsen herself has even said that
she's glad she didn't have to wear it - but
something closer than the one we were given
would've been cooler.
Apocalypse in X-Men: Apocalypse
Nobody in their right mind would have thought
a crossover between the X-Men and Power Rangers
was possible before 2016, but when images
of the titular villain in X-Men: Apocalypse
first appeared, some people were almost convinced
it was about to happen!Oscar Isaac's character
looked absolutely nothing like how Apocalypse
looks in the comic books and far more strongly
resembled a certain Ivan Ooze from 1995's
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers: The Movie.
The armour on this version of Apocalypse just
wasn't bulky enough and it didn't have the
obvious protruding cables hanging from it.
More to the point, it just looked cheap - like,
for example, it belonged in a movie that cost
$160 million less than X-Men: Apocalypse did
21 years prior.
It was also purple, which forced Fox to put
a blue hue on the movie to make the colour
more closely resemble the comic book version.
Patience Phillips in Catwoman
Michelle Pfeiffer might have hated her costume
in 1992's Batman Returns - she had to be vaccuum-sealed
into it and it was very uncomfortable for
her, after all - but at least she looked damn
good in it.
Halle Berry can't say the same for the time
she portrayed a twisted version of the character
in 2004's awful Catwoman movie.Aside from
the fact that the movie totally butchered
the origins of the character, gave her cat-like
powers and changed her name to Patience Phillips,
Berry's Catwoman looked ridiculous.
More specifically, her costume was absolutely
horrendous.
It looked cheap - like something from a low-class
adult show in Amsterdam - and, while it showed
a hell of a lot more skin than Pfeiffer's
version, it just wasn't as sexy and it didn't
quite have the same effect on men around the
world as a result.
Batman in Batman & Robin
1997's Batman & Robin was the worst Batman
movie of all time and, although the lead character's
costume wasn't that much different from the
one worn by Michael Keaton in the far superior
Batman and Batman Returns, it had one very
obvious flaw - visible nipples.
Big, prominent, distracting, Bat-nipples.The
fact that it was worn by the worst big screen
Batman by far in George Clooney really didn't
help matters, but the main point is that the
Bat-nipples are just downright unacceptable.
The costume also limited Clooney's movement
significantly when he was wearing it and it
had an extremely prominent, weird-looking
and slightly misshapen crotch area that almost
defied physics and, with all of those things
in mind, it absolutely has to be on this list.
General Zod and Co. in Superman II
This might be a controversial entry, given
the era of the movie in question and the popularity
of the iconic villains who wore the costumes,
but the fact is that - retrospectively at
least - these guys looked absolutely ridiculous.
We are, of course, referring to Kryptonian
villains General Zod, Ursa and Non – played
so memorably by Terence Stamp, Sarah Douglas
and Jack O’Halloran – from 1980’s Superman
II.What on Earth were they actually wearing?!
They genuinely looked like a corny Scandinavian
pop group in matching all-in-one playsuits.
Even in the early 1980's, that was hardly
a look that should have struck fear into the
heart of a superhero.
Harley Quinn in Suicide Squad
Ever since she first appeared in a 1992 episode
of Batman: The Animated Series - and in her
countless subsequent comic book appearances
- Harley Quinn's costume has caused controversy.
By the character's very nature, what she wears
is very sexualised and, over the years, it
seems to have gotten skimpier and skimpier,
but the latest version in 2016's Suicide Squad
movie has prompted the most complaints.Margot
Robbie's character has been given a completely
new look that some people are arguing isn't
anything like what Harley Quinn should look
like.
Her modern red and blue colour scheme is still
somewhat intact, and she wears short shorts
and stilettos like she has done in the comics
in recent years, but something about it just
doesn't look right - and Robbie herself has
complained that she got cold and wet whilst
wearing it.
Don't get us wrong though, the actress does
look sexy as hell, so we'll have to wait and
see if audiences take to the character with
this new look.
Thanks for watching our list of ten famous
superhero movies that got the costumes all
wrong.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other costumes were terrible in superhero
movies?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.